Saudi state media on Sunday broadcast
pictures of King Salman with the
kingdom's new ambassadors to Uruguay and
Ukraine the appearance of the monarch
followed speculation about his health
after the reported arrests of several
princes and dozens of officials in
recent days the king's younger brother
Prince Ahmed Abdul Aziz Al Saud and the
crown prince's cousin Muhammad bin Nayef
are said to be among those detained
taken by masked men to an unknown
location may be the health of the King
King Salman is deteriorating or again as
rumoured in the past he might be
considering basically abdicating and the
last thing Mohammed bin Salman wanted is
a challenge there are reports of an
attempted coup though some analysts
believe Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
is further consolidating his power I
understand that after the arrests of
these major figures that he then
demanded the other members of the family
to confirm their loyalty to him and many
were expected to tweet or to email him
and show that they were behind him
Mohammed bin Salman known as MBS has a
reputation for cracking down on anyone
who opposes him he replaced benaiah as
heir to the throne in 2017 forcing him
into effective house arrest MBS as uncle
Prince Ahmed was said to be concerned by
the crown prince's grip on power one of
a small group who voted against MBS
taking over this is something
extraordinary in Saudi politics Prince
Ahmed by the past rules of Saudi
politics should have enjoyed immunity
even if he was publicly a little
critical of some policy but that
immunity is gone there is no immunity in
Saudi Arabia Mohammed bin Salman can get
you no matter who you are that's the
message in 2017 dozens of senior members
of the royal family and billionaire
businessman around it up and detained at
a luxury hotel in Rio
the Saudi government said it was an
anti-corruption Drive rights groups
disagreed one year later Mohammed bin
Salman international profile was further
tarnished after the killing of Saudi
journalist Jamal keshavjee and the
kingdom's consulate in Istanbul the CIA
concluded that the crown prince must
have known about the operation if not
ordered it himself we know that he is
the the real power
there was some people calling him
anecdotally the Sun King the son of the
king but the person who is actually the
sovereign power in the Saudi state
reports suggest those detained now face
long-term imprisonment or even death
Alexei O'Brien al-jazeera